[Applaudissements]
il apprend regard à la cave genre est ce
qu'ils ont vu ou pato bourhis voulait
passer au petit dico jerada oui c'est
comme nous l'a déterré un râble elle va
vous expliquer des mots comme ça
l'équipe de temps en temps que si ça
vous plaît c'est le dico de gg
[Musique]
beaucoup d amis bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans le dico de maillé
aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre un
nouveau despote alors un despote
s'éteint comme qui doit traiter les
autres comme vih ils cachent tous les
gars qui sont pas de son crew hashtag
pas de sa team
le despote fait iech et si tu ouvres ta
gueule et mais lara sera comme un meuble
ou fragiles pour résumer le despote
c'est juste un tarbais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]